hi my name is Nicolas Wagner and I am
the math
coach for the barn in charge
initiative today we're going to be
talking about the use of the base ten
blocks and before we jump into the
actual use of the manipulatives I wanted
to highlight that in Singapore math
there are really three phases for place
value development the first is building
and renaming numbers so you can build
and rename the numbers then you're going
to change or rename and regroup numbers
so renaming regrouping and then lastly
you're going to build the four standard
algorithms okay the standard algorithms
that if you don't know what standard
algorithms are that would be the
vertical addition so 159 plus 400 64
where you're adding vertically and your
quote-unquote
carrying we're not gonna use that
language then we have the vertical
subtraction 215 for example minus 136
then multiplication would also be
vertical 245 times 3 and then the long
division it's gonna be your fourth
standard algorithm so those are the
examples of your standard algorithms
that you're building to now for
Singapore Math they don't start the
standard algorithms until the second
grade and the second grade is when they
do the addition and subtraction and then
and third grade is when they really hone
in on
the multiplication and division standard
algorithms so oftentimes your parents
are going to want to teach them the
standard algorithm I ask that you ask
them to hold off on teaching that to
their student to their kids your
students and so after you've already
gotten there and taught that the reason
behind this is that you really want to
focus on the development of the
understanding the concept before they go
into the algorithm itself so they want
you want them to understand addition you
want to understand long division before
they actually sorry division before they
actually get to those algorithms
including long division so let's do a
few few problems that are more
straightforward no renaming no
regrouping so we'll start with addition
way that you're going to do this is
you're going to have a place sorry
place value mat your ones tens and
hundreds and you're going to start by
saying somebody read that aloud to me
and you'll hear 123 and you say stop
great thank you
let's build that what is 123 and you
should be listening for something like
that is 100 two tens and three ones by
the time you get to this point they
should know what what that means they
should know that 123 is the same thing
as one 100 two tens and three ones and
they say keep going okay great
so they say 123 plus you say stop then
you ask them what is addition what is
what do you mean plus explain that so
every step of the way you're asking them
to explain it you're pulling it out of
them
so they're gonna say well it's combining
or bringing together so then you say
okay what am i adding to this what am i
bringing to gather with 123 I say 452
and then you're asking well build out
you say build it or name it show me show
me 452 so then they say for hundreds
then you have five tens and two ones
okay and again we're not renaming we're
not regrouping this one so this should
be understanding that now we're going to
combine these I have three and two makes
5 3 plus 2 is 5 2 plus 5 is 7 and 4
hundreds plus 100 is five hundreds so I
should have five hundred seven tens and
five 1s or 575 okay that is with out
regrouping let's go ahead and do
subtraction
let's do 359 minus 126 my apologies and
the last one I wrote it in the standard
algorithm form before you see this I
should make a note that it's not going
to be written vertically but
horizontally and the reason it's written
horizontally in your book is that
they're wanting to get in the habit
they're wanting students to get in the
habit of making those number buttons so
for a long time you're gonna be written
horizontally and not vertically so 359
minus 126 let's take these off so it's
not confuse
and the first thing you're gonna do is
say somebody read the problem so they're
gonna read the problem forgive me there
we go you can read the problem 359 you
say stop let's build that what is 359
it's 3 hundreds 5 tens and 9 ones and I
want you to notice the the way that I'm
placing my ones would be in line with a
10 frame so five across the top and then
there would be another row 9 would only
fill up four of those spaces in a in a
10 frame okay so we have 359 and so the
question is you keep reading and you say
359 - and you say what does that mean
and I should be saying take it away and
so you say ok take away what 126 great
126 I'm taking away so I'm gonna build
it right again the leading question with
the wrong answer you say no no they
should say no you don't build it you
take it away from the quantity that's
there so they say okay so how many do I
have to take away in the ones place I
have to take away 6 that's right so I
take away 6
okay and then how many ones am I left
with
three now I go to my tens how many am I
taking away from five tens I'm taking
away two tens great so how many tens do
I have left I should have three three
tens so so far I have three tens and
three ones and I'm taking away how many
hundreds take away one hundred okay good
so now I have two hundreds so 233 would
be my solution okay
so again not carrying sorry not
regrouping not renaming very simple
straightforward problem and I notice I'm
setting these aside over here so that I
can then check did I did I take it away
one hundred two tens and six ones yes I
did and now I have that left over here
okay so let's do a multiplication
problem without regrouping or renaming
which by the way the language of
instruction doesn't matter you want to
say rename or regroup as opposed to
carry or borrow and you're wanting to a
good phrase that I like to use is trade
in for because students know through
their years of experience with cards
like Pokemon or some other card game
that they have to get equivalent values
they know that they're not gonna get
ripped off so they want to trade
something equal equivalent with what
they have already so let's go ahead and
do another simple problem 230 sorry 230
two times two
so you're gonna walk through it again
you have asked them to build it say they
read it aloud 232 you say stop give to
hundreds you have three tens and two
ones and then you ask them what is what
is multiplication they're gonna say some
may say it's repeated addition
or it's multiples of of what you have
already there so you say okay so what do
I need to do to 232 I have to build it
again I have to build two of there
should be two sets of them so 230 okay
so now I should be good to go ahead and
combine them so I have two again I did
this wrong I should it should be 230 two
times two horizontal don't get them in
the habit of the vertical until they're
ready for it so two and two make four
and then I should have six here and then
I should have four here 464 okay
and now for a division problem
we can do 482 / - so I should have for
hundreds and then I should have eight
tens and two ones I'm dividing it by two
so I asked them what is division and a
lot of them are gonna say splitting into
groups and you want them to refine their
their explanation so and they say
splitting into two groups you should say
I need more I need more please tell me
more
what's wrong with just splitting it into
groups if I split into group so you can
say okay so this works and then this is
a group I'm gonna have knees here and
that's a group and there's nothing in
this group and they're gonna realize no
no no division should be equal groups
so in this problem I'm gonna have two
equal groups but I'm separating these
quantities in two so I'm going to mark
my board into two equal groups
okay so I'm going to start with my
hundreds and I say how many am I gonna
put in each group well they should
recognize from their math facts that
four is two groups of two but when you
ask them the question and they say two
belong in each group you should say how
do you know
tell me explain why do you why is it the
two should be in each group not just
because they're equal but why two not
three why shouldn't it be three in each
group or three in one group and one in
the other and then they get to the tens
and they're gonna say that four should
be in each group how do you know asking
that over and over again make that make
the students explain draw out that
explanation and then how many should be
in each of the groups for one for the
ones should be one in each group so then
you say how many groups of two are there
can you make in 482 or rather if you
divide 482 into two equal groups how
many are in each group so that's the
difference between partitive and quoted
of division what I just did there so you
can say 241 is in each group 241 okay so
I've gone through the problems with out
renaming regrouping or trading in now
I'm going to do a couple where I have to
regroup
and if you'll bear with me I believe
that it's worth seeing them for each of
the four each of the types of problems
each of the four operations okay so
let's start with 159 plus 464 and now
I'm gonna walk through this I'm gonna
walk through this with with the standard
algorithm so by this time they're
developing the standard algorithm and
they should know what that is
they shouldn't what sorry not know what
that is necessarily but they should be
learning what what's the standard
algorithm is so you're not afraid to be
using it right now because it is the
appropriate time so we have 159 yes
students to build it I'm sorry
105 tens and nine ones
and then you're adding or combining for
hundreds this is the second number six
tens oh good I have some and for once
okay so it's important here when you
combine them what you're wanting to show
them is nine plus four or nine once and
four ones makes thirteen once but I
can't write a thirteen here without
running into the tens place so what I
have to do is I have to regroup or trade
so I have to make a group of ten I'm
going to take this one here
make that group of ten and I'm gonna
trade that group of ten with ten ones
with 110 I think it's helpful for some
students when you're initially you're
doing this to line up the 110 with the
ten one so they see that those are
equivalent again they're used to trading
and they will recognize if you're trying
to rip them off so those are equivalent
my bars my and if it was there a little
bit warped so it's not as obvious but
now I have instead of those ten ones I
have 110 I'm gonna take that 110 and I'm
gonna put it here so I'm taking 110 and
putting it here these are going off to
the side and how many ones do I have
left
I have three ones left so I had 13 ones
I made a group of 10 ones to trade for a
10 and I traded that and I move that one
10 I mean the 10 ones will change into a
110 over to the tenths place now I'm
gonna do a similar thing
with with my tents so I'm gonna group my
tents into a group of ten tents
okay because I realized that five plus
six plus one is more than I can put here
it's gonna be 12 I have twelve tens I
recognize that so I'm gonna make a group
of ten tens two will be left I'm gonna
trade these ten tens for one one hundred
again you can put those next to each
other so they see that the values are
equal equal I'm gonna take these and
move them out of my tent frame I'm gonna
take this one hundred and I like to draw
the arrow to show I've moved this over
and that arrow aligns with drawing that
one right there so I'm moving like and
they do this I'm going to move this one
hundred there so now I have two tens
left I still had the three ones and now
I'm to my hundreds and I have one two
three four five six hundreds which lines
up with my four plus one plus the one
the ten tens that we trade it as a
hundred six hundred twenty-three so
there's the addition for you with
renaming and regrouping next we are
going to do I'm going to go ahead and
skip the subtraction and a
multiplication and jump to the division
if you would like to see a sample of the
subtraction and multiplication which
you're gonna do something very similar
to what you did with this problem
I have on box a PowerPoint with
manipulatives already listed on there
already shown and you just have to click
through the animations to see those step
by step drawn out for the division let's
go ahead and do seven hundred six
divided by three 706 divided by three so
you're going to start by asking them to
build it 706 so that's seven hundred
seven hundred and six ones oops
all right and so now I have 706 and
recall you're gonna get them to explain
that it's separating these into equal
groups specifically three equal groups
so I'm gonna mark on your board and you
have group one two and then give three
down here see okay so I'm gonna ask them
how many of these can fit into each
group equally and they're going to tell
you to again use this time to ask them
lots of questions how do you know it's -
why is it - things like that and you say
oh no can I just put this here and they
say no and you say why not and they say
hey I'll say something to the effect of
now they're not equal so I ask them what
do I do with that hundred and what I do
with that hundred they should know is
this 100 is equal to ten tenths so I'm
going to trade this 100 for ten ten
so I man take this let me make sure that
I I'm following my sequence here go go
back for a minute I had seven one
hundred six divided by three I'm doing
them again the standard algorithm so I
moved to into each group and I therefore
I am using six and how many do I have
left I have one left that cannot be
split into those groups equally okay so
let's go back here now I'm trading that
ten that's a terrible night the ten tens
for 100 or rather the 100 for ten tens
I'm gonna set that aside
I'm gonna move these over here and I'm
gonna draw this arrow again I traded the
hundred so this is my hundred it's not
there anymore it's now ten tens and
notice how many tens were there before I
move those ten tens over there were zero
well that's what this is here it's a
zero so now I have ten tens and this
line starts to make a whole lot more
sense wait some people use the place
value notation above above the problem
so they can see if those place values
matter in the long division so now I
have ten tens how many of these tens
going to each group I have three groups
three groups of three you can ask them
why is it not four how do you know it's
three instead of four and they say well
it was four times three is twelve well
why do you multiply by three get them to
explain it over and over again so I have
three in each group and so I've used
three groups of three which means I've
used nine and I take away nine from the
ten and I'm left with one ten now can I
use that can I put that one in these
others no so I I my students quickly
realize I need to trade that ten
and 410 once and it looks like I might
be one short oh it's subtle here we go
okay so I trade that in now I'm gonna
move this over here I can if this helps
you can draw it on the board and cross
it up so they see that and so I'm gonna
take these ten ones and I'm gonna move
these ten ones over here okay and so how
many ones do I have now how many did I
have there to begin with
sorry I had six to begin with and now
how many do I have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
12 13 14 15 16 yes I just counted for
you I had one 10 and there were six ones
there already so I should have 16
I should have 16 that makes sense this I
take this and I say I changed it in for
10 once so then how many are going to go
in each group you say five in each group
and it should be noted that for a time
there you might use the concept of
remainder as our so you've used three
groups of 5 which is 15 how many did you
have left in your ones you had one left
so you have 235 remainder one you solved
that problem using the manipulatives
alongside the standard algorithm so they
see in each group 200 200 is 3 tens and
five ones so there are either you can
either visualize this as three groups of
235 or you can say 2 you can say that
there are two hundred thirty-five groups
of three and 706 ok so those are the
addition and long division algorithms
again you can read you can check out the
subtraction and the multiplication
algorithms on box on our box link if you
don't have that please feel free to
email me at in Wagner at Hillsdale dot
edu thank you very much